exclusive video showing the moments
right before a horrific crash up in
north las vegas police say the driver
hit speeds above 100 miles per hour so
tonight traffic safety leaders are
shedding some light on the issue of
habitual speeders on our roads victoria
saha live to explain how widespread this
problem is victoria
it's hard to imagine driving at
lightning speed in our roadways but the
sad reality is it happens more often
than we realize and in an instant it can
turn deadly but we must remember that
lives are on the line any time we get
behind that wheel
this is what driving at more than 100
miles per hour looks like seconds later
the same driver caused this horrific
crash saturday killing nine leaving a
mom to mourn her six kids this week had
a different vibe to the conversation
about the need for action
i think there's a lot of people
frustrated an eye opener for everyone in
the community in a virtual meeting
nevada advisory committee and traffic
safety says their big push for 2023 are
automated traffic enforcement which
includes cameras to catch speeders we
don't have enough officers on our
roadways
we need a metric to keep them
accountable we received new numbers from
the nevada department of transportation
and safety they say in 2021 more than 5
thousand citations were given out in
nevada for people driving more than 100
miles per hour it's crazy because you
know we have kids and
the speeding and everything so when i
first came out here i was like what is
wrong with las vegas drivers a constant
reminder of just how dangerous the roads
can be when someone isn't following the
rules definitely a lot of reckless
driving going on
out of those 5 000 citations given out
last year in nevada 2600 of those were
right here in clark county victoria saha
live local now